I love being with people it's the
most incredible thing in the world
what are you doing oh this is nice
that world may change and evolve
but the one thing that will never
change we're all part of one big family
that man next to you he's your
brother that woman over there
she's your sister hire further
faster baby that's right
we're all part of one universe that moves
ever upward and onward to greater glory
on your left
avengers
assemble
i've lived a lot of lives
but i'm done running from my past
we have unfinished business who's we
when you love something you fight for it
we're the ones who changed everything
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my brand
new marvel trailer video they released a whole
bunch of new marvel phase 4 trailer footage so
we'll break it all down there's a whole bunch of
easter eggs here we finally got an eternals teaser
trailer and a whole bunch of other stuff from the
other movies as well as confirmed dates and some
big title reveals for stuff like black panther 2
which is now titled black panther wakanda forever
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of course i'll be
doing videos for all these things there'll be more
trailer footage coming really soon this is mostly
just meant to be a general hype reel to remind
everybody that theaters are reopening and please
buy movie tickets that's why they say see you
at the movies at the end of this and they even
included the footage of the avengers end game
in theater reactions with the crowds going crazy
during the portal scene that's actually a fan's
footage that they put in that that isn't somebody
from marvel like a fan recorded that in a theater
posted online and then marvel is now using it in
their trailer footage usually when that happens
marvel actually has to contact the person that
that belongs to and get their permission even
though technically they were illegally recording
their movie inside a theater you're not supposed
to do that but because it was such a powerful
moment marvel's like okay we'll let this slide
because it's so cool and it works perfectly
for their whole campaign here to get people
back into theaters like hey movie theaters are
slowly dying please everybody buy movie tickets
because we have all these cool movies that are
coming to theaters real soon but because there's
so much stuff in this big giant marvel phase 4
trailer in addition to the new eternals footage
i'll talk about everything shot by shot as we go
through but like i said they're trying to hype up
people going to the movies that's why they start
with the stan lee voice over part at the beginning
of the trailer with him talking about loving this
human experience of it all making people happy
being with people seeing their reactions to the
stories that marvel published in the comics then
when they started making the movies his speech
applies to a lot of the comic book stories that
he published during his lifetime but then also
obviously now because this is all about the movies
they eventually started making movies and
we started seeing that reaction in theaters
that's why they go through the progression
of marvel phase one phase two and phase three
footage while he's talking about his voice over
before they start showing the new marvel phase
4 footage and why they don't include any footage
of the marvel disney plus series in this because
this is all about the movies getting people back
to the movies so to speak we just went through
the entirety of 2020 a whole year without any
new marvel movies which is crazy to think about
there are four marvel movies coming next year
and another four coming during 2023 also funny
thing here too even though they're celebrating
the movie so to speak going back to theaters
black widow for instance is a special case being
released on disney plus and in theaters at the
same time all the other movies going forward after
black widow though are going back to the regular
release strategy where you only can see them in
theaters then eventually many months later once
they hit home video then you can watch them on
disney plus and what i'm going to do because
there's so much footage in this is i'm just going
to focus on the eternals trailer footage and i'll
talk about the other new trailer footage for the
other movies in separate videos later this week
so the trailer footage actually jumps around in
the timeline a lot they're thousands of years
old during the movie as the name implies they are
eternal if you haven't read the comics they can
also resurrect themselves so they've died and been
brought back to life several times in the past but
the present day of the movie will be after the
events of avengers end game and during the film
they will explain why they were not around for the
battle against thanos for the events of avengers
infinity war avengers endgame that's one of the
biggest questions like if they're so powerful and
they're trying to defend humanity for thousands of
years why weren't they around for this big battle
but this first scene is of sama hayak's character
ajax she's playing a female gender bent version of
the character from the comics who acts as sort of
a leader figure and administrator for the rest of
the eternals she's sort of like a mother figure
big sister figure but they're all crazy powerful
they all have cosmic level powers given to them
by the celestials she's just a voice of authority
amongst the eternals well they're all busy doing
their own day-to-day things around the world but
if it wasn't clear they were all created by the
celestials at the same time so they were all
born quote unquote or born again at the same
time because it's basically the celestials
modifying regular humans and giving them these
celestial powers they're like the next closest
thing to mutants inside the mcu but technically
because they weren't born with their powers you
refer to them as mutates not mutants in order to
be a mutant you have to be born with your powers
it's a little hard to tell when this scene of
her on horseback is happening because it could be
present day but it's just her riding around on
this horse funny side detail too this scene of
them on the beach and all their costumes
was shown off a couple years ago at ccxp
in 2019 that's how long they've been sitting
on all this footage it's some of the eternals
not all of them and this figure on the far left is
barry kyogen i'm probably mispronouncing his name
he's playing druid one of the deviants and one
of the main antagonists of the movie but he's
not meant to be the actual main villain he's more
of a loki type of figure the way they're using
the deviants during the movie is just a little bit
different from the way they use them in the comics
so i'll explain that in a second they're making
a couple changes to the eternal's backstory in
the way they present them inside the mcu but for
instance thanos is actually of the eternals thanos
was born to eternal's parents it's just that
he was born with the deviant gene which is why
he looks the way he does his parents look like the
other eternals like just normal people with cosmic
level powers but that's one of the reasons why
thanos is so naturally powerful even without the
infinity gauntlet and why he's so long-lived he's
much older than thor and in the mcu thor is close
to around 14 1500 years old remember asgardians
live for about 5 000 years give or take so the
asgardians like odin thor they would probably know
about the existence of the eternals but this scene
of them on the beach is supposed to be a wedding
i believe in the way they talk about it you hear
salma hayek's voiceover in the trailer saying
when you love something you fight for it that's a
reference to this wedding like the eternals loving
each other fighting for each other and a reference
to the eternals loving humans humanity wanting to
fight the deviants the celestials to save earth
defending the planet from alien invasion so to
speak only this time it's not thanos and the
infinity gauntlet showing up with their army it's
the celestials using earth as their own personal
experiment in hatching grounds for more celestials
the celestials themselves are kind of like the
real villains of the movie in a way they're more
like cosmic gardeners that destroy whole worlds
build whole worlds just as a matter of course
through their normal actions going around the
universe their whole purpose is just go around
and just experiment with life and when experiments
don't pan out they basically wipe it and start
over again so during the guardians of the galaxy
footage when the collector is explaining the
history of the universe the history of the
infinity stones and you see the celestial this
is eson the watcher you see him use the power
stone to sort of wipe a planet that's basically
a planet that the celestials deemed where their
experiment did not pan out so it's like okay we'll
just garden this weed away and try something else
but what the celestials are using earth for does
threaten to destroy it but the whole idea is that
they're not evil like the celestials aren't evil
themselves they're just cosmic gardeners and we're
like the ants running around in the garden so if
a gardener is weeding a garden so that it will
grow properly and some ants die in the process is
the gardener an evil person you do have the idea
of celestials that go rogue just a little bit like
ego the living planet is a celestial character and
he was trying to take over the entire universe
terraform it into more of himself but obviously
he didn't think of himself as evil even though
he threatened all life in the universe if he
were unchecked but this wedding scene just seems
like it's between sprite the little one on the
left here and sersei's character gemma chan she's
supposed to be the main character then around them
in the background this person on the left next to
druid might be sama hayek's ajak it's kind of hard
to see her face here this is angelina jolie's
thena character and this is bryan tyree henry's
phastos character i believe this scene on the
beach here is meant to be taking place a long
time ago way before things go off the rails then
you get a shot of them all together at a village
this is kumail nanjiani he's playing kingo this
is sprite the little one like i said gemma chan
sersei next to her then richard madden's ikaris
then thena and then this is gilgamesh on the far
right then this scene thena fighting someone
at night in her armor with her special sword
from the comics seems like she might actually be
fighting gilgamesh but it could be another one
of the deviants it's kind of hard to tell because
the scene is so dark then this other scene of them
from thousands of years ago is in ancient babylon
the attack seems like they're in the middle of a
war or some kind maybe it has to do with their
battle with the deviants before the celestials
threaten to show up in present day but you get to
see ajax salma hayek use some of her powers not
all of them just some of her powers it's her thena
gilgamesh ikaris and kingo then just reminding you
that the release date is going to be in november
before spider-man no way home there's also a lot
of disney plus stuff coming out later this year
but like i said this trailer is just meant to be
for the marvel movies there's another tag scene
here with what seems like sersei in present day
she might be talking to kit harrington's dane
whitman character in present day talking about
we're the ones who change everything just sort of
explaining their history to him during the course
of the film he's playing the black knight during
the movie i'll talk about him more in a second
because the way that they're introducing his
character is sort of like the fish out of water
who's learning about the eternals for the first
time like we've been amongst you this whole time
for thousands of years then the scene of kingo is
in present day and he's supposed to be posing as a
bollywood movie star in present day so this might
be a scene of him filming one of his bollywood
movies and this other guy standing next to him in
this shot is just another actor inside that movie
the whole idea is that during the film before
the events of avengers infinity war and after
avengers end game they're sort of all out in the
world living lives amongst humans as if they were
normal humans without their memories so they don't
remember that there are turtles and that's why
they weren't around for avengers infinity war
like they literally didn't remember that they
have special cosmic level powers but that's
all because of a big twist involving sprites
character in some of the events of the film so
i don't want to give away two big spoilers but
they're actually doing a lot of the plot based on
neil gaiman's eternals run from a couple years ago
but it's not the exact comic book story they're
just inspired by that neil gaiman story the other
big change that they're making to the eternal's
backstory is that the celestials are using planet
earth as sort of a breeding ground for another
new celestial like they've laid a celestial egg
inside planet earth that takes eons to hatch
like many many millions billions of years and
after the events of avengers end game the egg is
getting ready to hatch and when it does this giant
celestial will hatch out and wind up destroying
the earth and the eternals are trying to stop that
they're also changing the deviance backstory
during the movie and that'll explain why they
also look exactly like the eternals because in the
comics most of the deviants look like monsters the
whole idea with kit harrington's character dane
whitman the black knight is that he doesn't know
a whole lot about his family's lineage but it
is pretty close to the comic book plot where he
is just the latest black knight and is sort of a
title that gets passed down along with the ebony
blade in his family's curse there's a romance
between his character and sersei during the movie
in present day but i believe those two characters
are also supposed to cross over into avengers 5
because both of them were members of the avengers
a long time ago in the comics so everybody let me
know if you spotted any big easter eggs in this
footage from the new footage that i didn't talk
about during the video i feel like i covered most
of it my next video will be for that new chongqi
trailer footage so that should post early tomorrow
they also just announced dropping a brand new loki
trailer tonight so that'll actually probably
be my next video i should be able to get that
up later tonight while you wait for everything
click here for my brand new black panther 2
killmonger video and click here for my last big
shanxi trailer video in easter eggs thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe
and i will see you guys at the movies!